with more rain and potentially dangerous
flooding for the Gulf Coast in what's
shaping up to be a wet Mother's Day for
much of the nation drivers battled
another night of heavy rain in Houston
where even turning around from a flooded
street was hazardous this man's truck
landed in a canal after he tried to
avoid the high water there was lightning
rain and thunder in Southeast Louisiana
Friday there's the potential for flash
flooding in Texas in Louisiana again
today meteorologist Jeff bardelli is
tracking the storm Jeff good morning hey
good morning Anthony good morning
everybody that is the big story today
the potential for more flooding we have
saturated ground we have watches and
warnings blanketing all the southeast as
you can see in the areas we're watching
most closely especially around Houston
up to around the Louisiana area not much
yet but watch out over the next couple
of hours here's what's happening we have
a weak to moderate El Nino so warm
waters in the Pacific Ocean fueling a
strong subtropical jet stream pulling
moisture out of the Gulf of Mexico and
so once again today another round of
very heavy rain and storms as well let's
show you the Future radar right now
there's not too much on the future radar
but you'll notice as we head through the
morning watch the rain develop right
along the southeast coast of Texas and
eventually moving into Louisiana as well
there's the possibility of some severe
weather in terms of how much rain we're
gonna see generally about 2 to 4 inches
of rain over the next couple of days and
we'll probably see some places pick up
about six inches of rain and for the
moms let's talk about Mother's Day a
little bit of Mother's Day misery in the
Northeast high temperatures only in the
upper 40s breezy
rain heavy at times and the possibility
of severe weather in the Carolinas Jeff
thank you stay inside snuggle with your
kids right